[Music]
ed i'd love to know and if if there's no
answer that comes readily to mine that's
fine as well but
i'm 45 and i'm wondering or roughly 45
after
some thinking you know i am roughly at
the the midpoint to
my my next target which is to get to
your age and then from there to 120 or
who knows where you know by then the
world will have changed a lot and your
odds will be a lot better
one can help a boy can dream so i i hope
that is the case and that we're not
living in some dystopian future where no
one has any reproductive health so i am
i am hoping for the the upside case
let's assume that is true what are some
of the
the new beliefs or changes in beliefs
that
most positively impacted
your second half
and of course um this is self-serving
and it's it's possibly a hard question
but how did your thinking or priority or
beliefs change
kind of after the after the midpoint
that you think retrospectively looking
at it have most benefited you or those
around you
i started running
probably when i was about 40 just
a mile or so on a saturday and then i as
that we talked about last time i built
it up then i started actually running
marathons when i was 47. so i got into
running very late
but marathoning taught me quite a bit
about life in a way because i began to
say to myself you know life is a lot
like running a marathon
and
if you look at it that way
here i am at that age then back in uh
roughly around 50. here i am at the
midpoint
perhaps of a marathon
so if you're running a marathon you
don't sprint
because you'll burn yourself out early
you
are careful not to step in potholes
there are all kinds of other things that
you need to take care of in order to get
to the finish line and you eventually
learn
some of us learn how to get through the
wall without there being a wall anymore
which took it took me seven marathons to
figure that one out
and
so i thought to myself well
the same thing about life you if you
plan ahead you can avoid a lot of
problems that uh sink other people
knee replacements
heart clogging up
catching diseases because you don't do
proper vaccination
going to
countries where there are horrible
diseases to catch in the first place and
you can't protect yourself fully maybe
that sort of thing so
thinking long term is one thing that
running a marathon teaches
us
and so i tend to think long term anyhow
but that was a great reinforcement
in the last say five to ten years is
there anything you've
profoundly changed your mind about
or it could be recently i don't need to
put a time frame on it
to me the value of
being around good people
and not being around a few bad people
is uh
much higher than it ever was before
and the people in my life i consider
the most important and my actions with
good people the most important thing
you know i enjoy other things but i
think
at this age
you've basically done
most of the stuff
that you're going to do of any general
broad significance and so it's a time to
reflect
and think about life
and enjoy it and if you have any if one
has any wisdom to
assure to some extent
well you seem as sharp and as lively as
ever as far as as far as i can tell i
mean you you certainly have more
vitality
however i know that's a bit of a maybe
an italicized word but
life force than a lot of the
40-somethings i know so whatever you're
doing keep keep doing it and is there
anything else
ed that you'd like to add before we
bring this conversation
to a close
i think
an important thing for everyone
is to think about
the world and society
as
us
instead of
me and to try to act that way
and to think longer term think about
how the things one does affects
the people around not only right away
but down through the years
and it might seem like it doesn't matter
but it does in a way and a lot of these
things will
that you make better now
for the future will actually
benefit us a lot sooner than you might
think otherwise
pollution for example you know climate
change is is coming along that's coming
along pretty fast
and people might say well
what do i care about what happens 50
years from now
but it's happening in increments
it'll be a little worse next year a
little worse the year after and so on
and you might not want to be around when
it's really bad 50 or 100 years from now
but you might not care because
you're only going to be alive another
10 years let's say if you're a pretty
old person
but
still these things come along
sometimes faster than you think and in
ways that you don't expect and so it's
wise i think to just try to make the
world a better place in any way you can
even though you might not reap all the
benefits
yeah here here
you